tensions were boiling over in the fight
over fairness in women's sports
[Music]
that's activist ambushing former
Collegiate swimmer Riley Gaines after
she gave a speech about saving women's
sports Gaines says she was attacked and
forced to barricade herself in a room at
San Francisco State she's been outspoken
about the topic since competing against
UPenn high-profile swimmer Leah Thomas
this cast comes as Biden Administration
is now pushing to block States from
blanket bans on transgender student
athletes
um Jesse as I understand the Biden
policy you know Title IX right prevented
discrimination based on gender now this
new rule prevents goes a step further
and prohibits discrimination based on
gender identity so it says these schools
have to recognize whatever anybody says
their gender is
they give them little outs
and I read the outs and it looks like a
lawyer's dream I'm sorry judge but a
lawyer reads this new rule and they just
see cash then the schools have to hire
more lawyers all of these trans
activists athletes will hire lawyers and
they'll just litigate the hell out of it
and that's the problem with this it's
not a solution unless you're a lawyer
and then it's a cash register why aren't
girls trying to play on boys teams do
you ever wonder that you never hear
about these girls going out for
wrestling or boys lacrosse or football
or track it's always these guys that
want to play on the women's teams and
they're the ones destroying Fair
competition they're the ones making the
locker rooms uncomfortable no one wants
to go the other way I find that
interesting because they suck that's why
they suck the guys suck and they can't
compete against me and so they go to the
and everybody knows and everybody's
afraid to to say that look everybody
knows I'm a libertarian I will call
whatever I would go along with whatever
you want okay but there's something that
is happening with this movement and
anytime you have a movement that is
Untouchable and cannot be checked
problems happen and everybody knows that
it's a issue of fairness and it's not
just this issue either it is the drag
shows we know that kids shouldn't be
going to any sexually explicit event
shouldn't be a strip club shouldn't be a
director but you can't say it because
it's offensive group The Standard when
there is a dossier of a killer whether
you're white supremacist a black
supremacist your release of dossier you
can't release the dossier in Tennessee
it's been weeks no comment about it at
all why so because of identity and
everybody knows it included including
the other letters in lgbtq but they
can't say it themselves because they get
isolated as well so the Dems gotta check
their movement and this identity
politics thing is a dangerous game
because real people get hurt check your
movement take a look just quick take a
look I'm going to get judge and Jessica
your reaction to this Riley Gaines video
let's take a quick listen
Charlie Brown
[Laughter]
trans
fers
[Music]
what do you think
I think it's a continuation of what I
was saying in the last block it's part
of the lawlessness that's going on in
this country where people for whatever
reason think that if they yell the
loudest if they victimize themselves and
say I'm a victim here then they get
their way and the majority of Americans
don't agree with these loud mouths and
in the end you know they're winning so
you get a President Who forbids schools
from uh who receive Public Funding from
Banning any kind of boys transitioning
to girls teams from preventing you from
Banning them going on uh girls teams and
the truth is in Title IX was there for
equal opportunity for women and this is
just the opposite it it undermines Title
IX of equal opportunity for women saying
men who are stronger than you are and
who better to talk about this than Riley
who was beaten by Leah Thomas who's the
guy what is wrong with us what is wrong
with us with sex in schools
five-year-olds six-year-olds and you got
Gavin Newsom running around saying they
suppressed speech and they're burning
books and all this nonsense it is
nonsense this is not normal what's going
on in America we are upside down
um Jessica to the judge's point we're
having this argument we meaning America
is having this argument about this right
now in sports but the issue is actually
much broader it impacts other elements
of American life definitely I I went out
on the sports front America is pretty
unified on this Democrat independent and
Republican that they don't think at the
competitive level when you're talking
about scholarships to go to college
college sports professional sports that
the rule that transgender people should
be able to compete same as biological
females so just want to put that out
there but yes it is seeping into other
aspects of society and it hit close to
home for me so I went to all women's
college I went to Bryn Mawr one of the
seven sister schools and Wellesley a few
weeks ago the student body voted to
admit trans students and this was
vehemently opposed by the head of the
school Dr Paula Johnson who said that it
was a betrayal of the mission of the
school trans people of which gender well
actually it'll end up being both people
who were born biological female and now
live as men and people who were born
biological men and now live as women and
what the students were arguing was that
these schools were founded as a safe
haven for people facing gender
discrimination and I can understand the
connection there to say that these
people who do face gender discrimination
but as someone who very intentionally
went to an all women's college it's very
hard for me to wrap my head around the
idea that if my daughter if Cleo decided
that she wanted to go to Wellesley or
Bryn Mawr I'm sure will end up taking
the same stance on this that
she might be in class with biological
men living in dorms with them sharing
bathrooms these are all things that I
think folks kind of take for granted or
don't think about the actual specifics
of it but it changes the shape of what
the education is it's a it's a women's
education I'm not saying that I'm just
blanket against it but it was a real
shock to the all women's college Jessica
what's wrong with that if you as a mom
said you know what I'm compassionate I
support it poor Transit gender folks
doing whatever they want to do but I
don't like that I don't like that that's
them well I I just said that it was
something that I wasn't particularly
comfortable with and that I don't think
it is the mission and when you look at
who went there Hillary Clinton Diane
Sawyer you know these are people who
intentionally chose women's education
did you go to in all worlds all the
people that Jesse really admire there's
a lot of value
the fastest is coming up next stick with
us hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now